okay hello welcome to this video I had
some issues with selling of that board
so it took me a tuck me a moment them to
start this game yeah get this funky line
again with 93 it's not that great i
think Knight a5 is a good funny way to
play here let's just do that I'll keep
that pawn I'll just be an annoyance with
about that porn okay but how to play now
push up f4 maybe just develop gather
night only five it's a funny funny piece
but yeah not not easy not easy for white
to get the bond back now but how do I
develop with e-cigs probably okay okay
ed okay bye take now is good 'if five
maybe oh yeah hmm should have thought
about that a little bit a little bit
longer maybe maybe i can maybe i can go
90 form now it's not thinking about this
at all as usual i keep wasting time on
moves that the opponent is not even
considering in the slightest okay so
well i can just take and something like
wind is 64 our simple chess or just
castling actually I'm just castling is
okay okay i can take d5 just
keep that take that pawn keep it
okay so i watch now maybe here and then
like Knight B 3 and B 5 one night coming
to d4 would be good I knew some 94 here
right looks good too centralized that
piece now be five coming yeah just be
five looks looks fine
okay so Queen t-64 third trades maybe
you can go at four but this is not
knocking before you can play it's not
terribly bad but still I like the idea
to provoke that move okay but I don't I
mean if I go f5 now should have three
yeah I'll sure that it helps maybe just
centralized
96 maybe to check the f porn well f 59
probably not but I can go g5 maybe
simply force the trade yeah that's
probably not so bad I don't know if you
can't avoid the trade now I don't don't
see how check ya know up for brooke d 3
b3 check check rugby three
look at five maybe still somewhat
annoying
and he basically has to do that yeah
okay
I have no really sharp continuation that
that would help
94 also does it help remarkable not so
easy maybe this one who have 69 f 4 then
taking between next so tries to take g5
so we'll just see three I guess should
be okay Jack time warning
c2c to evolve playbook c5 fatigue g2 is
that enough maybe nights not okay
probably need the need the beep on as
well
fatigue now know what's not working it
was far that was not enough what I did
when I got all of this by far not just
very bad technical flame check check
check I have to secure the draw now by
liquidating the pawn check jolly was bad
we're being drawn yeah that should be a
win like her out of the opening I also
never tried to get any kind of
compensation you just very willingly
went into this lost end game which I
failed to convert I think this should be
kind of okay I also think that g5 is ok
it's not the easiest way maybe but it
should be enough check the how where did
I screw it up as I don't think that this
should be should be the problem check
three
before so yeah it's a complete win but
how did why don't I win Rookie to is
strong I don't get it this this this
move why's that winning then this one oh
come on yeah that's not exactly so
simple that this wins yeah I mean ok
once you see it but poo ok man this is
just drawn unfortunately no it still
wins see to irock v3 check and Roxy
three of course and i'm promoting mmm
yeah this and this and he resigns so it
was a win and it was a win but yeah well
here here it's of course just to draw
but i have to yeah also I cannot try
anything whatever that might be it is
dead wrong but I just have to take the
take this draw by yeah getting rid of
his final porn okay well thanks for
watching